a year and a half after cambridge
graduates jack merritt
and saskia jones lost their lives we are
for the first time
seeing footage from inside fishmonger's
hall of attacker
asman khan at an event that had been
about rehabilitating prisoners
he can be seen here in the distance
talking to 23 year old volunteer
saskia jones they were sitting just two
seats away from each other
moments before he stabbed her to death
jack merritt though
was the first to lose his life after a
break outside
he returned to the bathroom where in a
cubicle
khan had stashed a black bag and tied
two knives to his hands
police believe the arabic word for allah
had been scratched onto the eight-inch
blade
khan was ready when jack merritt arrived
and it was there that he stabbed the 25
year old to death
jack's mother and merit told the inquest
that he was a good person
she said jack was forced for good in the
world someone who made other people's
lives better for knowing him
she said his death was a tragedy but his
life a triumph
saskia jones meanwhile was taking part
in a breakout event
she also went on a break outside when
she re-entered
khan had emerged from the bathroom he
stabbed her once in the neck by the
cloakroom
today in a statement her family said
that it would be her hope
that no other family is devastated and
heartbroken again in similar
circumstances
they said she should be defined as
someone who battled to improve the lives
of others
in several spheres and was driven to
make real changes in the world
some of the footage that was shown to
the inquest was just too graphic to be
released
we saw images of jack merritt falling
against the door at the entrance to
fishmonger's hall with blood on his
shirt
and then usman khan moments later
fleeing out towards london bridge with
two knives attached to his hands
when khan fled fishmonger's hall he was
being pursued by ministry of justice
employee with a narwhal tusk
and an ex-convict with a fire
extinguisher polish kitchen worker lucas
seen here at the top was injured trying
to control khan
six minutes after the attack began
police fired their first shots khan had
been wearing a fake
explosive belt that the inquest heard
had been made of xbox components
and bandages wrapped in cling film usman
khan
died at the scene on london bridge the
inquest
into his death will begin once the jury
have considered the deaths of two young
graduates
whose lies were cut short ali fulski sky
news